imagine an evolutionary hierarchy  starting with the very simplest thing  that can possibly be imagined something  perhaps mathematical something geometric  but really simple a simple code and it  gets more and more complex in its  emergent behavior and up and up and up  and up and then at one point it gets to  such high levels of complexity but all  built with the same underlying code that  it actually is complex enough to hold as  the substrate the code itself and then  you take this linear hierarchy that's  that's ranked from simple to complex all  the way up to source and you just wrap  it into a circle okay  we're like the Ouroboros the simplest  part the code is embedded within the  mind of the most complex part the  emergent godhead of source and in this  sense it is logically consistent all the  way through